we have a voicemail number and that
number is 219 to david p if you have
anything to say
comment question
concern
complaint you can call 2192 david p you
know in the midst of all of these
problems for the right here's a caller
reminding us about a very important
story that no one's talking about
anymore listen to this
uh
dave this is chuck from minneapolis yes
the obamas for that
if you forgot about obamacare you know
what it is all right thanks bye yep
whatever happened with obamagate you
might remember that during donald
trump's first and so far only
presidential term he started talking
about obama gate which he described as
the greatest political crime of the
century
when he was asked sir what is obama gate
he angrily told a reporter in the press
briefing room you know what it is
and no one knows what it is but if there
is anything ripe for a raid
i guess it would be this vague obama
gate i don't know we have a great bonus
show for you today in the midst of all
of this economic good news and bad maga
news joe biden's approval rating has
spiked to its highest point in two
months
things are really turning around for
this guy we're going to talk about it on
the bonus show we will also talk about a
new report that says rainwater is not
safe to drink because of the chemicals
that are in it and we will talk about
the growing sort of i hate to call it
this but it's kind of a pissing match
between apple and samsung or really
iphone and android where texting between
the two platforms is increasingly broken
i'm going to explain to you what's going
on in the behind the scenes of it very
very interesting
uh corporate wars all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show pac-man's
a loser alex jones hates the bonus show
i love the bonus show and i would love
for you to sign up at joinpackman.com
see you there today
or tomorrow on the friday show